hi this is Amira city and I'm working
emotional learning team or from research
and today I will be talking about new
unsupervised learning functions in
version 12 of Wolfram language
hello everyone can you hear me everyone
hear me all right good so today I will
be talking about some new functionality
that we introduced in version 12 and we
stored sweet so let's see we first start
with find anomalies and anomaly
detection and then we talk about
synthesized missing values so these are
all purely supervised learning functions
and I will tell you how probabilistic
modeling gives rise to developing these
new functions to find and isolate
anomalies and also to missing fill in
missing parts of data so first I will
sort with anomaly detection and find
Anneliese so what is the goal here so
given a list of examples it can be
numerical data it can be nominal data
and we can ask or it can be images we
can ask what are the data that are
somehow different from the rest from the
majority of these so I will explain
detail what do I mean by being different
and it has it can be very useful in many
areas like fraud detections monitoring
server for suspicious attacks cleaning
data restructuring data and in some
literature's it is also called outliers
instead of fine anomalies or anomaly
detection so we introduced four new
functions related to find anomalies its
anomaly detection and I want a detector
function and find anomalies and delete
around Lee's first I will sort
which few simple examples first find
anomalies you can just give it data
which no I think and it would return the
anomalous examples you can ask for
different properties like anomaly
positions by default it returns the
animals example that it thinks that is
different from the other ones you can
ask for properties like anomaly account
you can use it for different things
images colors and so on the derivative
function of this is delete anomalies
that it would delete the example that it
thinks that it believes its anomalous
the other main function is anomaly
detection which returns anomaly detector
functions so you just give it a training
data to trainee anomaly detector
function and it will give you a small
icon that have some description about
the method that it uses that I will
explain later number of examples in the
training and then this new detector
function you can use it to find
anomalies on new examples and it returns
a true and false a boolean list
indicating which examples are anomalies
through our non anomalies false you can
also use anomaly detector function the
first argument in find anomalies and as
a second argument you can give it a list
of new examples that you want to detect
anomalies in so just as a side note
current version of the function won't
support finding anomalies for example in
a given example if you have one image
and you want to find some anomaly in one
image or you have a time series and you
want to find anomaly a rare event there
this does not work it is another example
among other examples
so we hope that you would have that
feature in the next part so but let's
think about what is an anomalous example
so if we go and look at naively a
Wikipedia we come up with this simple
definition that rare items is really
suspicious by differing significantly
from the majority of the data so
examples being different somehow
but what does that mean first let me
tell you that if anomalies are not too
diverse and you have a lot of anomalies
you can have a supervised learning
approach and if you have labels for some
data with labels that are anomalies or
not and can use classify for that but
here for fine anomalies and related
functions we are focusing on a problem
where you don't have that many anomalies
there are rare and you cannot get that
much information about them
so anomalies would be things that are
you have a lot of a bigger space and
have little data so supervised learning
approach would will fail to identify
those and we can formalize here this
problem using probabilistic approach by
learning by modeling non-anomalous data
and figure out how extreme and example
is so these are purely unsupervised
approach to anomaly detection so but how
this formula our formalism work so let's
assume that the data is generated based
on some distribution there's an
underlying distribution that of
non-anomalous data that we somehow know
what that is so by distribution I mean a
statistical distribution so an anomalies
here would be the examples that are out
of distribution
this is a very essence of a density
based methods here so we are strictly
speaking about out of distribution
example by saying it is the probability
to generate samples with a lower PDF
then they give an example for a specific
distribution so it means that the total
probability of all examples whose PDF is
smaller than the given example so it
means that you're trying to measure how
rare one event is one example is so you
can see that yes all the total
probability of any events with PDF lower
than and give an example X so for
example for a given distribution a
normal distribution will be between 0
and a standard deviation of 1
generally we can ask for error
probability of generating 4 so it will
be very rare very extreme event to have
number 4 so we can think of this rare
probability as a generalization of a
p-value for non-normal distributions and
we introduce rare pollutant version 12
and you can use it like first argument
would be the distribution and the second
argument it would be the example that
you would want to know how extreme that
example is given a distribution so
examples are considered anomalous if
their corresponding rarer probability is
below a given acceptance threshold just
to be clear
rarer probability is not the anomaly
probability it is just a measure of how
extreme one event is so we can ask for
the rare ability using
animal detector function training
detector function with a normal
detection for example on a set of random
real numbers between zero and one and
two dimensional vectors and you can call
with the probability with the property
rarer probability and for example you
see that this first example since the X
component is 5 it would give you a
various smaller error probability so
this would be considered anomalous but
you can change this acceptance threshold
for their error probability below which
that one example would be considered
anomalous also by hand the default if
you don't specify it it's one in
thousand but let's take a look at this
acceptance threshold so we create a
random 3d vector of anomalies just few
of them with negative values and the
majority of data is random real numbers
between 0 & 1 so you can see the animal
is here and the majority of data are
normal data here so if we can just use
find anomalies on this set of data and
it will give us identify correctly these
anomalies which automatically accept our
threshold but say you want to put an
acceptance threshold point two which is
pretty large it's like 20% and you will
start to see that it will pick up points
at the edge of the cluster of the
nominal data
also as anomalies so these are the
points sitting at the tail of the
distributions so in general if data
comes from the same distribution as you
have for the data for training your
detector this acceptance threshold would
correspond to a false positive rate that
like these points that are normal but it
would find it
anomalies so but first we need to find a
distribution on anomalies free data data
without any anomalies so this is the
ulema here because on one hand first the
ideal case is you have a training data
with no anomalies so you can train it
and then you can use that ml detector
function on new examples but what if in
your training data you would also have
anomalies so this is like even the
distribution without anomalies but you
need to the point is you want to find
anomalies first so this is like a
chicken and egg problem so there are a
few methods to resolve this problem one
method is cross validation type method
that you split the data to training and
testing and you train on some examples
and you test the distribution on other
examples and you pick the ones examples
with a small probability as anomalous
and then you do it vice-versa after
removing all the anomalies by
cross-validation you retrain a
distribution on the anomaly free data
and this method would work if you would
have no duplicates in anomalies but if
you have like anomalies that are similar
to each other in one point you might put
too much mass distribution on top of
that and you would make the probability
density large on those points and you
just make mistakes there are other
approaches like clustering type approach
that you start with a small set of data
that you're confident that is normal you
train a distribution on that and you
keep adding more and more data and you
grow your normal seed and you would have
stopped until you
it's um threshold and whatever is not in
the back of your normal points would be
considered anomalies so this method also
can easily fail if you have a group of
points that are like further apart so
this growing normal growing process
might stop early and you would live with
a lot of normal data that you think that
are anomalies but they are not so for
the for we implemented the first method
and we will add the second method and
more methods in the future let's look at
properties of some practicality of using
these functions so you can use find
anomalies with different properties you
can ask for anomalies which is the
default and it will return the examples
that things or anomalous you can ask for
anomaly positions where in the list
those examples exist non-animal is the
normal points and at least that is
anomaly boolean list which is a
true/false boolean is indicating whether
the examples are true or odd or
anomalies or not and rare error
probability for each of them so let's
look at one application of anomalies in
four images so here I get a training and
test set of MMS data images of
handwritten digits and I also make a
test set with few anomalies a picture of
the monkey and a image of a player noisy
digit I just add it to my test set so
this is like the cleanest way that you
can use anomaly detection that you train
I just train
on the digits that I know that it's
without an anomaly and then you can
specify the methods so the methods are
the same as learned distribution methods
so I just pick multi normal you can also
use a performance goal so at the core of
anomaly detection function it's it's the
learned distribution and their methods
are the same for learning the
distribution and then you can learn the
anomaly detector function on your images
and you can use find anomalies and the
test sets with the animal detector
function that you trained and you would
see that it would pick out out of these
digits and anomaly cases they're ones
that are not anomalies like many times
it might especially for images because
the space is large and probability
densities are a little bit hard to
define in a larger spaces in
multi-dimensional high dimensional
spaces you might need to manually work
with acceptance threshold to make it
smaller than what we have right now we
resize all the images and conform it to
the same size so if you have different
size images no it won't find it as
anomalies yeah so and you can also look
at after training your anomaly detector
function you can look at the information
and you can get the summary of the
training process that you had like you
can get a data type it's image like
what's the dimension what's a method
what's a loss function and so on so
for the so this was all about animal
detection and find anomalies so briefly
I would also talk about another
unsupervised learning function that we
do which is synthesized missing values
the goal of it is filling missing values
in an example for a generated value so
by default if you have a data set with
symbols missings and in determind it
would pick them up as missing values and
it would just fill new values for that
so the formalism is that you retrain a
distribution on not non missing data and
then we condition that distribution
unknown variables for example here we
have like the first variable the X
variable to be missing so we condition
on wide the second variable and we find
their probable this condition
distribution and we draw a sample from
it from this condition solution so there
are two ways that we can draw a sample
we can just draw a random sample or we
can get their most likely sample and
which correspond to a example with a
largest probability so we can just use
synthesize missing value directly on
your data with missing values or you can
have a learned distribution and learn
the distribution in advance on your
training data and you synthesize missing
value first argument we do learn
distribution and second argument to be
the missing part so but let's take a
closer look how it works so imagine I
have a to to model distribution to multi
normal distribution of different mean
and with different covariance and you
see the regions of high probability
closer to the crowded regions and so on
I just generate a list like 20
candidates for one data point with a
missing value on
y-axis so and I just like plotted here
and you see that it follows these
candidates of missing values follows the
distribution strictly speaking the draw
from the same distribution conditioning
on one of the missing one of the unknown
variables but you can also ask in the
method to find the most likely example
with mode finding and you would see that
by these purple points that it would go
and sample from the part of the region
of the probability distribution with
highest largest problems so these are
the most likely cases so in general you
can set your method by to have different
learning methods for learning the
distribution and evolution astrology for
could be random sample or mode finding
so I told you that by default signalize
missing value would pick missing and in
this remind as missing but you can
change that there's an option missing
value pattern you can tell that like
four is missing just feeling where we
receive four or we can have a function
where ever you sees anything smaller
than three just treat that as missing
this would be useful for example for if
you have corrupted images here again I
have MS data and I train a distribution
on these pixel that on these images and
I just made some corrupted images and I
say that it should consider the pixel
value of 0.5 is strictly the color gray
as missing and it would fill in that
with the drawsome
for those and would fill in the thing
that it just imagined it kind of the
model i let the model to imagine what
should be in those areas so in the
future we would have a pre trained
synthesizer that you don't need to train
it especially for things like images
that might take time and would have the
representation of missing values for
different type of data and so on so I
will finish here and I would be happy to
take any questions
[Applause]